THEIR WAY TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
IN EUROPE.
CNN SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT REPORTS.
>> THE FASTEST GROWING REFUGEE
CRISIS IN EUROPE.
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
SPILLING ACROSS THE BORDER OF
THE FORMER SOVIET UNION.
MORE THAN 1.7 MILLION UKRAINIANS
LEAVING EVERYTHING BEHIND.
AND NOW RELYING ON THE KINDNESS
OF STRANGERS.
PEOPLE LIKE THIS GRANDMOTHER.
WHO SAYS A RUSSIAN STRIKE
DESTROYED HER FAMILY HOME.
ON FRIDAY.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT THE DAY WOULD
COME WHEN WE WOULD HAVE TO RUN
AWAY WITH THESE LITTLE KIDS.
HOLDING HER FOUR MONTH OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER.
NEARLY EVERYONE HERE LEFT THEIR
HUSBANDS, FATHERS AND SONS
BEHIND.
TO DEFEND THEIR HOME.
MOTHERS WITH YOUNG CHILDREN NOW
ON THEIR OWN IN A FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
>> IMAGINE IF YOU HAD TO PACK UP
YOUR CHILDREN.
YOUR PETS.
YOUR BELONGINGS.
INTO A SINGLE SUITCASE.
AND FLEE YOUR HOME AND YOUR
COUNTRY.
ON A MOMENTS NOTICE.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENED TO ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE.
MOLDOVA A SMALL RELATIVELY POOR
FORMER SOVIET REPUBLIC OPENED
ITS DOORS TO THE REFUGEES.
PROVIDING FREE TRANSPORT.
HOT MEALS.
AND SHELTER TO TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF UKRAINIANS.
SAYS THE COUNTRY'S PRIME
MINISTER.
>> THREE-FOURTHS OF THE REFUGEES
ARE ACTUALLY STAYING WITH
FAMILIES.
A LO OF THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
FRIENDS OR RELATIVES IN MOLDOVA.
ALSO REGULAR PEOPLE HAVE JUST
TAKEN IN UKRAINIAN FAMILIES.
AND INVITED THEM INTO THEIR
HOMES.
>> COMPLETE STRANGERS.
>> YES.
>> THIS WOMAN IS TRAVELING
ALONE.
SHE CAME FROM KYIV.
AND IT TOOK NINE DAYS TO GET
HERE.
SHE HAS FAMILY WAITING IN
MOLDOVA.
>> THE WOMAN IS HEADED TO MEET
RELATIVES HERE.
IN AN ARENA IN THE MOLDOVA
CAPITOL.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF RUSSIA INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
HUNDREDS OF UKRAINIANS WHO HAVE
TAKEN SHELTER IN A STADIUM.
IN MOLDOVA.
THIS A TEMPORARY STOP A PLACE TO
PAUSE AND PROCESS THEIR NEW
REALITY.
>> THESE WOMEN TELL ME THEY
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY WOULD SHELL AND BOMB
THEIR HOME CITY.
A CITY WHERE ALMOST EVERYONE
SPEAKS RUSSIAN.
AFTER ALL, PUTIN CLAIMS HE IS
PROTECTING RUSSIAN SPEAKERS.
FROM UKRAINIAN NATIONALISTS.
>> THEY SAY LOOK, LOOK AT WHERE
THE RUSSIAN SPEAKING PEOPLE ARE.
THEY ARE ALL SLEEPING HERE.
>> THIS OBSERVATION ECHOED AT
THE BORDER.
BY 65 YEAR-OLD GRANDMOTHER.
>> WE WATCHED THE RUSSIAN TV
CHANNEL.
AND THEY HAVE IT ALL BACKWARDS.
THEY SAY THE RUSSIANS ARE HEROS
DEFENDING US.
LOOK HERE.
HOW THEY'RE LIBERATING US.
IS THIS A LIBERATION?
SHE ASKS.
IF I'M RUNNING AWAY WITH A
LITTLE BABY LIKE THIS.
SHE JOINS THE CROWD LINING UP
INTO WAITING VANS.
ONE OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
UKRAINIANS NOW FACING A VERY
UNCERTAIN FUTURE.
>> JOE IS THE SPOKESPERSON FOR
THE UN INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR MIGRATION.
HE JOINS ME NOW.
FROM MOLDOVA.
THANKS FOR DOING SO.
I WAS READING ON THE WEB SITE A
COUPLE DAYS AGO.
YOU WROTE ONE DAY THEY WERE
CALMLY GOING ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS.
THE NEXT THEIR WORLDS WERE
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN.
THAT REALLY DOES SUM UP WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO MILLION OF
UKRAINIANS.
HOW BAD IS THE HUMANITARIAN
SITUATION?
>> LET ME TELL YOU NEW FIGURES I
HAVE DIRECTLY FROM OUR DATA
TEAMS.
WITH THE BORDER POLICE.
273,500 PEOPLE HAVE CROSSED INTO
MOLDOVA.
ABOUT HALF OF THEM ARE STAYING
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE REST ARE GOING ACROSS.
THAT'S ACCURATE INFORMATION.
WHAT WAS SEEING IS A PAINFUL
PICTURE OF FAMILIES BROKEN
FAMILIES.
FROM ACROSS THE BORDER.
MEN HAVE TO GO BACK.
GOING AS FAR AS THE BORDERS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND WALKING BACK.
INTO A VERY UNCERTAIN FUTURE.
AND SENDING FAMILIES TO AN
UNCERTAIN FUTURE IN MOLDOVA.
AND FURTHER.
TODAY INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY.
AND THERE ARE WOMEN LOOKING
AFTER THEIR FAMILIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THE THAT UKRAINIANS
HAVE GOT INTO.
THEY'RE IN NEED OF GREAT HELP.
ONE THING OF COURSE THEY NEED
MATERIAL AID.
AND WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE
NEEDS, FOOD AND WATER.
WARM CLOTHES.
BLANKETS AND SO ON.
PEOPLE NEED PROTECTION.
FAMILIES ARE BEING RIPPED APART.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY'LL SEE
THEIR PARTNERS AGAIN.
IT'S A VERY SAD SITUATION.
AND WHAT WE'RE ALSO DOING IS
CAPTURING --
>> SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT.
THERE'S A DELAY.
I APOLOGIZE.
TALK ABOUT THAT.
IT'S HARD FOR MOST PEOPLE TO
GRASP THE LEVEL OF OUR UPHEAVAL.
THEY SIT AT HOME AND WATCH THIS.
LEAVING YOUR HOME YOUR CITY,
YOUR LIFE.
WITH WHATEVER YOU CAN CARRY.
THEN LEAVING YOUR COUNTRY.
TRY TO DESCRIBE WHAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTE TURMOIL.
IT'S JUST ALWAYS BEEN ESPECIALLY
KYIV.
EUROPEAN CITY.
TO THINK PEOPLE HAVE TO FLEE
THERE UNDER FIRE.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING UNTHINKABLE.
FOR PEOPLE.
I WAS MARRIED IN KYIV.
SO IT'S -- FRIENDS ARE STILL
THERE.
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN TORN APART.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S APART
FROM MATERIAL AID AND CASH.
IS SOLIDARITY AND KINDNESS.
WE WORK UNDER THE PRINCIPLES OF
HUMANITY, INDEPENDENCE.
AND NEUTRALITY.
THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF EUROPE
AND THE WORLD HAS TO EMBRACE
THOSE PRINCIPLES.
AND REALLY SHOW SOLIDARITY AND
KINDNESS TO PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PEOPLE LIKE US.
WHO AS YOU OPEN YOUR THE SPEECH
WITH.
THE FUTURES SOME OTHER COUNTRY.
NO MATTER HOW LONG THIS
CONTINUES PEOPLE NEED WORK,
CHILDREN NEED TO BE EDUCATED AND
PEOPLE NEED HEALTHCARE.
IT'S MOLDOVA JUST TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE.
WILL PLACE A HUGE BURDEN.
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT ENORMOUS
ISSUE HERE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE MIGHT SEE
A COUPLE HUNDRED PEOPLE ACROSS
DURING THE DAY.
NOW TALKING ABOUT 20,000.
IN ONE DAY.
WE'RE WORKING TO HELP GET THEM
TO OPEN NEW BORDER POSTS.
AND RESOURCING MOBILE DOCUMENT
READERS.
AND AUTHORITIES KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE ARE.
AND WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
>> YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT ABOUT
MOLDOVA.
270,000 WHO PASSED IN.
THAT'S LIKE 5% OF THE
POPULATION.
IT'S A SMALL COUNTRY.
THE RESOURCE BURDEN IS HUGE.
THE REALITY IS THE DEPENDING ON
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD.
THIS COULD BE A YEARS LONG
PROBLEM.
FOR UKRAINE AND EUROPE.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT NOT BE GOING
HOME FOR A LONG TIME.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
WE HOPE FOR A POSITIVE OUT COME.
EVEN IF PEOPLE CAN GO HOME.
WHAT DO THEY GO HOME TO?
PEOPLE HAVE LEFT IN HUGE NUMBERS
AND WILL NEED ALL THE THINGS FOR
DAILY LIFE.
THAT WE NEED TO SURVIVE.
WONDERFUL THINGS ARE HAPPENING
ACROSS EUROPE.
THE CITY IS GIVING FREE
TRANSPORT TO THE UKRAINIANS.
PEOPLE ARE OPENING UP ALL THE
AIRBNB FOR UKRAINIAN REFUGEES
AND VERY CONCERNED AS WELL THAT
THIRD COUNTRY NATIONALS PEOPLE
AROUND UKRAINIANS PASSING
THROUGH.
INTO MOLDOVA.
25,000 THIRD COUNTRY NATIONALS.
COMING FROM 140 I THINK
DIFFERENT NATIONALITIES.
LEAVING UKRAINE.
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE MAYBE
STUDENTS OR WORKERS OR CITIZENS.
THEY'RE LEAVING THE COUNTRY AND
HAVE A VERY UNCERTAIN FUTURE.
THEY WILL BE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE.
>> IT IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
IT'S LIKELY TO GET BIGGER.
WE HOPE THAT THE GENEROSITY AND
PATIENCE OF NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES AND ALL OF EUR